at the ball out of him beats hands  before he hears on that's a very good  point and Oh Marcus smart and impedin  Pete's going right back at him the  Sixers wisely keeping him beat away  [Applause]  and people's looked like he was ready to  go for the fight and tonic  almost seemed like he gathered himself  itself it's making sure they get smart  away from him  [Applause]  comes right after that we players  let's take a look all right I see that  left arm come out that's what he didn't  like smart pushes up to the floor that's  gonna get smart toss ya left arm the  elbow he elbows him no / - so does is  this the initiation then has something  to say so does he you know subjected to  anything might because he instigates it  but smart that's probably gonna cost him  the rest of the ballgame right yeah I  would say so  probably a key  [Applause]